how you doing you conspiracy
theorists and right-wing nut jobs i'm
dave rubin
it is march 30th 2021
and this is the reuben report direct
message as always click that subscribe
button and that notification bell
and perhaps you'll see our videos in
your feed although right before i
started this
about 20 seconds ago in real time
i saw from the official youtube twitter
account that they are going to be
testing out
hiding dislikes on videos
because it's become very obvious that
they don't like their creators or their
users
and they don't want real feedback to be
there by the way our
like to dislike ratio is bananas amazing
it's off the charts like look at any of
our last videos like it's actually great
because i think we put out decent
content and although i do have
a lot of loser trolls that hang around
and most of them are on twitter anyway
we get a great ratio but what they don't
want you know the white house of course
shut off
their comments on their videos and now
they also get ratio to high hell on the
like dislike thing
so they don't want that either so
youtube they're just
whittling away all the ways we can
communicate with each other in an
honest way and we shall just get
information from verified authoritarian
sources
because they know what's good for us now
sit there and be quiet all right guys we
got three stories for you
but before we do any of those stories i
just want to throw to one quick video
of kamala harris this is video from the
white house yesterday
and if you thought biden has mental
problems well
take a look more people are seeing
that yeah affordable child care is a big
deal
more parents are seeing the value of
educators
when they had to bring their kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
what i mean she's off a rocker like
we're used to like
generally evil politicians i think
everyone sort of accepts that
politicians are mostly generally evil i
mean they
spend their lives trying to control
other people's lives but she's like
maniacally evil
you know this is a woman who polled at
zero percent in her own party got zero
delegates
in the primary then they chose her for
identity politics reasons
she's got that evil cackle and she's
just laughing for no reason
there was nothing funny being said there
let's throw it one more time
more people are seeing
that yeah affordable child care is a big
deal
more parents are seeing the value of
educators when they had to
pregnant kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
more parents are seeing
value she's a combination
of of the joker and
green goblin or something i i don't know
what she is i think the reason she's
laughing is she cannot believe she's
going to be president
it's it's all so idiotic and she's like
i'm going to be president any day now
and she actually
can't believe it also why is she wearing
a mask she is roughly how old is she
she's maybe 45 something like that
probably 45 she's perfectly healthy
she's been vaccinated she's on a stage
alone
it's all theater people there's no
business like show business all right we
got uh
three stories for you one we're going
very heavy on covid stuff today because
there's a lot of
bananas things to talk about just like
the vaccine passports and the head of
the cdc is having a mental breakdown
and i'm sure we can come up with
something about fouchy so we'll show you
a couple videos on that
uh the second story i think is actually
really important and sort of hits
close to home in the world that i live
in uh which is
that um on bill maher's show
on friday night which i feel like it's
really losing its influence very fast
you know
his his focus on sort of that that good
liberal that still considers themselves
a democrat and says their free speech
but you know the real scary thing is the
conservatives
and the trump people like that just
doesn't really fly anymore i think you
guys know my
my feelings on that and again i would be
happy to discuss that
with with bill maher any time uh but
anyway
uh former senator from north dakota
heidi heitkamp
was on and they started talking about
gina carano and you guys all know that
what happened to gina carano when she
got cancelled by disney
and gina carano basically called her a
nazi and a white supremacist and there
was no pushback from mar and i just
think it's a perfect
sort of like bite of everything that's
wrong with everything
labels media the whole damn thing oh and
then finally
um a california lawmaker not too far
from my house
is trying to push forward on a bill to
hold big tech accountable
for online hate which you know if the
government
forces private companies to restrict
speech
you might think that maybe that's a
violation of the first amendment it's
sort of an
outsourcing of tyranny so we're going to
get to that but before
we do any of that stuff people i want to
talk to you about bonner private wine
you know the next time you grill up a
couple steaks
pop open a bottle of extreme altitude
malbec wine
it comes from these remote vineyards in
argentina located around 9000 feet
when these vintners aren't making wine
they're herding cattle so they know
meat they know barbecue and that's what
these malbecs are for
as soon as you open the bottle you're
going to experience delicious notes of
blackberry leather smoke
and a little dark cherry you're also
going to get less sugar less chemicals
and less additives and 10 times more
resveratrol
which is a powerful longevity booster
we've been drinking these malbecs all
the time you guys know about my my meat
habit and i'm telling you they truly are
delicious
the guys over at freethinkerwine.com
just got a special shipment of these
wines in they've got one mile back from
the third
highest vineyard in the world i've got a
bottle of malbec
right here i can't drink when i'm on air
because i'm a professional
but i want to and that's part of it
visit
dot freethinkerwine.com today and you'll
get 50 off your wine and 50
off shipping that was it's a small batch
and it's gonna go fast just
visit freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay so we're gonna
do a whole bunch of stuff
on kobit right up top so there was video
from c-span yesterday
where joe biden at this point it seems
to me that we are watching the federal
government sort of just collapse at
every level they are just throwing out
the kitchen saying keep the masks on
vaccine passports nobody go to work
maybe go to a barbecue in four months
like
none of it really makes sense i think
everyone's starting to tune out and
ignore most of this stuff which is
probably good
right and i am not a scientist i am not
a medical doctor
but i am a citizen of a of a somewhat
free country at least for now and my
belief is that you should do
what is best for you and your family and
then we'll see what happens from there
if i was in charge right now truly if me
dave rubin was in charge i would
absolutely 100 open up
everything and you take what precautions
you want to take and let's see what
happens why did we never try that for
three days
why did we never try that for three days
and then look at numbers
you think it might be because these
people like locking you down like
destroying your lives
they like this idea of a vaccine
passport they like the idea of
controlling who can get on a plane and
who can go to
stadiums and who can uh you know be a
part of free commerce and all of those
things or
i should say not so free commerce anyway
uh old joe was given a speech yesterday
and he's not happy that some of these
states are
reopening even though it's going really
really well there and we'll get to that
in a sec but first
here's joe i'm reiterating my call for
every governor
mayor and local leader to maintain and
reinstate the mass mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require masks as
well
thank you mr president do you believe
that some states should pause the
reopening efforts
yes
okay i want you guys to do a little
homework on today's episode of the
reuben report direct message i want you
to google the numbers of texas and now i
believe it's 18 days since they opened
up
and in 18 days the numbers have
precipitously dropped
dropped and people have been able to go
back to work joe biden has no
well not only does he have no authority
i would argue as president of the united
states to force individual states to do
anything
that's a separate sort of legal issue
right
um but i would say he has no science to
back what he's saying he
just wants more and more control
he or whoever's pulling his strings
because obviously it ain't joe imagine
if joe had to do something for three
straight hours
imagine if you had to babysit a
five-year-old and a seven-year-old for
three hours
the kids would be dead and the house
would be burned down okay the guy's
obviously not in charge of anything i
mean that's just
it's just painfully obvious i'm sorry it
just is what it is
but the idea that now florida should
reverse course when things are going so
well
and texas should reverse course but the
reason he knows he can lie about that is
because the media will just keep lying
about these states
i mean they'll just keep doing it over
and over so
it's not just now that the president
wants to trample on the rights of free
texans
and flee and free floridians who voted
in the right people
but now people and we've got a headline
from the post-millennial
vaccine cards are on the way yeah that's
right this was like an alex jones
conspiracy theory
six months ago and now apparently it's
true vaccine cards to rival passports
as essential travel documents
we're all used to having to pull out our
passports when we go on vacation but as
forbes reports quote
your most precious travel accessory this
summer is going to be a small
white piece of paper um
you know i don't want to uh overstate
the
the nazi thing we talk a lot about nazis
these days
um but you know one of the things the
nazis were known for
show me your papers what kind of accent
was that that was a terrible accident
wait i can't do it do i do a german
accent show me your papers no that's not
germany either
uh give me show me your papers no that
wasn't
better no that was a little better you
just have to say i was just angry
your papers please how was that that was
a little bit your papers
no i want them the point is guys this
isn't about whether i can do accents or
not and i'll
talk to my uh vocal coach on that um
the idea that now to travel from state
to state to get on planes
to go to stadiums to do all of show me
your papers nah damn that's not right
to do any of this stuff that you're
going to need to carry around a white
little piece of paper and government
authorities will be able to see it even
if you're
you're young and perfectly healthy and
not obese and not 80 and don't have a
co-morbidity
two weeks to flatten the curve is anyone
paying attention to any
of this stuff this feels like this is
sort of what i was saying before this
sort of feels like just like a
hysterical government that has
completely lost control just throwing
everything at us
at the last second just to endlessly
keep us afraid that's what it feels like
to me
and by the way you know i see some
people saying well no it won't be the
federal government or even the state
governments that'll force you to do this
you'll just have to have these things if
you want to go to a baseball game or if
you want to go into a mall or it's up to
the private companies to do that
but once that starts we know it never
ends with that and it'll just keep
moving and moving and moving and do you
want to just be walking around
with papers all the time that anyone you
know is that any government authority
like we're just
giving away all of our liberty show me
your papers no
damn what is that's french damn
show me pepe no
this is not good this is not good and
i'm not just talking about my accent
okay
it's just not good guys we got to do
something about that
peperos please no sarah
no
there's so many god everyone's talking
about nazis all the time i can't even do
their accents anymore because we've said
everybody's a nazi and now
i do a nazi accent sounds like pepe le
pew who's also been canceled
um anyway the problem here of course is
that they're gonna just keep throwing
all this nonsense at us
uh but there are some decent people
in government i could probably count
them all on one hand one of them is ron
desantis in florida this is video from
the recount
uh him talking about how he's going to
stand up against vaccine passports
you want the fox to guard the hen house
i mean give me a break
i think this is something that has huge
privacy implications
it is not necessary to do you know we're
going to have hit
three and a half million seniors that
have gotten shots uh
sometime this week likely 75 percent of
seniors
it's important to be able to do it but
at the same time
we are not going to have you provide
proof of this
just to be able to live your life
normally and i'm going to be taking some
action
in an executive function emergency
function here very short
i want to see your peppers huh no can i
see your peppers
show me your peppers it's all becoming
french damn
anyway the point is that guy knows what
he's doing that's a great man
that's a good state why do i live here
i've got to talk to my people
um then of course if you think this
isn't getting even more
bananas and and i try to show you the
banana stuff and then of course like the
little ray of light that comes from
florida usually
um but the cdc director
a woman by the name of rochelle
wallensky uh
she is now very very concerned that
things are about to get
much much worse just as they're telling
us that things are getting much much
better take a look i'm going to pause
here
i'm going to lose the script and i'm
going to reflect on the recurring
feeling
i have of impending view we have so much
to look forward to
so much promise and potential of where
we are
and so much reason for hope but right
now i'm scared
that's the cdc director telling us that
she has a feeling of impending doom
lady get on some celexa lexapro
well a butrin smoke a joint i mean for
god's sakes you people are supposed to
be calming us down
you have a feeling of impending doom she
knows there's no impending doom coming
her impending doom
is that her grift is almost up that
we've all wised up to all of the
nonsense and we're not listening to you
people anymore with your conflicting
messages
and your never-ending cascade of rules
that we have to pay attention to
that you don't even pay attention to
themselves so yes there is impending
doom but it's basically that
you're just not going to be someone that
we pay attention to anymore but really
if
she does i mean joking aside if she does
have the feeling of impending doom
there are medications for this sort of
thing and you know just
go to your doctor they love to prescribe
these things you know some of it causes
diarrhea
and flatulence and thoughts of suicide
and
depression and all those things but then
you can take another drug to
fix those things which then cause other
side effects and then you can take
another drug
to fix that you know it's a lot so i get
it
rachelle you've got problems and uh you
know we hope it works out for you
um all right so this friday this past
friday
on the bill maher show on hbo and let me
preface all this by saying that i
basically like bill maher for most of my
adult life and career he was someone
that really influenced me
i think some of his stand-up specials
especially when they were really topical
during the george w bush
years about iraq and free speech and the
patriot act and all that
very good i think bill maher does get it
on free speech but bill maher at this
point i would say he's so rich and such
a celebrity at this point that he's sort
of checked out
and then every now and again he says
something
three years after some of us say it
online and then everyone's like oh bill
maher gets it on free speech bill maher
gets it on what's happening in schools
but
but it's like yeah this has all been
happening forever so
i just sort of it's weird the reason i
mention that actually is because
that show seems to still be a weird
airlock i would say the online world has
completely
basically overtaken the television world
at this point
but there is still value in the
television world because of the money
that's there
that just keeps like people it just
keeps certain people elevated
and that real-time show still seems to
be like an airlock
between the online world and the
mainstream world something like that
um but and and by the way i know that a
lot of you guys at the
real-time show you watch this show for a
lot of your ideas i've got my insiders
um so how you doing people uh anyway uh
heidi heitkamp who is the former senator
from north dakota
she was on the show this week she's
sitting next to by the way
my buddy nick gillespie from reason
magazine who i realize i have not had on
the show before who i absolutely
will have on the show and they were
talking about gina carano now you may
remember about
month month and a half ago or so gina
carano was
kicked off the mandalorian show on
disney plus
basically because she's a conservative i
mean that that is really what it all
boils down to or in effect she's just
not woke i actually don't know that she
fully says
she's a conservative um i don't know
that she considers herself a republican
but she's non-woke
and she had posted a meme basically
saying if you keep demonizing people
that you're gonna end up treating them
like jews during the holocaust which is
a true premise
if you keep othering people that's how
you make these things happen that's how
you make
good people do horrible things anyway of
course she got called a nazi and all the
rest of it
disney got rid of her and okay that
that's where we were at well then the
story sort of went away but then it came
back this friday let's take a look
i like this picture uh who was the woman
in the
mandalorian what did she do she liked
something she's a nazi
oh that's different right i'm thinking
of somebody else well she's not a nazi
she's she was
she's awake
um she does hang with white supremacy
it's like a mel brooks it does
yeah hangs with whites i suppose i'm now
get subject to defamation i i don't know
i mean it depends on what your
definition of white supremist is that
you're so
the goal post there changed a lot of guy
in a clan hood who
but i think we have to i think we have
to be really careful there's two things
the republicans think they're going to
get biden
on cancel culture and this whole dr
seuss stuff that's going on where
they're reading
green eggs and ham proving that some of
these senators can actually read
and and and
and immigration and and and so
we can't ignore the fact that we got
donald trump was in part because
of political correctness all right
heidi heitkamp this one goes out
directly to you you're not a good person
now you know that gina chrono's not a
nazi the way you
moved your eyes and shook your head and
kind of laughed through it you know
that it's you're a liar and
this is this is what progressives do you
just label everybody whatever you want
to label with
them and realize it sticks and by the
way it's very obvious that you didn't
believe it because then immediately
after then you sort of change it oh
she hangs with white supremacists what
white supremacy talking about
orthodox jew bill maher bill maher
orthodox jew ben shapiro
like what are you talking about but this
is what they do with everyone
what's interesting about that was bill
maher it's like shouldn't you have some
concept of knowing what you were talking
about he was like gina chronos she
posted a picture or something something
and like there wasn't much of a defense
given there i always give hosts a
certain bit of a leash there
because i know when you're sitting with
someone and everything and it's all
happening live
like you're trying to give people the
benefit of the doubt and everything else
i i wish my buddy nick had jumped in a
little more
a little more aggressively but bill had
pointed the question to heidi heitkamp
um but the point is i think gina carano
should consider suing her
you cannot run around calling everybody
nazis that's what these people
have decided to do you're nazi you're a
white supremacist this is the exact
thing
that disney plus unjustly fired
gina carano for and heidi heitkamp knows
it's not true and this is what they're
all doing and this is what they've used
to keep a whole bunch of us silent and i
think the only thing
that we can do i think we have two tools
i actually think we have two tools in
our hands right now
to to stop this nonsense one is a legal
tool like some of this
these people are going to start having
to be sued into oblivion right like
we have libel and slander laws they're
extremely extremely tight which is why
they're
never used i mean think about how often
i'm called a white supremacist or
alt-right by the new york times or all
these things
and it's like i've had lawyers approach
me actually extremely well-known lawyers
from from extremely reputable firms
and say dave you know you want to sue
for libel you want to sue for slander on
some of these things and i have
considered it over time not in the last
couple years but when it was all first
starting
five years ago and jordan peterson was a
nazi and you guys know all the stuff
it was like it was so shocking it was so
shocking as all i kept doing was
defending liberalism
and that thus i was a white supremacist
which by the way bill maher makes a good
point on that which is that years ago
a white supremacist meant you wore a
hood you were a member of the kkk
now it just means you're not a
progressive nut bag
so bill i'll give credit where it's due
he does get the ever moving
um the ever ever expanding
definition of what a white supremacist
is but i would say that that the legal
measures
are really the are the one sort of
tangible thing but then the other thing
and i really think this is it more than
anything else is we all must just start
speaking up
that's it like that really is it i think
most people for some reason
think that someone's gonna come save us
i think most people are sitting around
like oh
this craziness can't last forever
eventually
it will die out and blah blah yes it
will die out but the question is how
much destruction will it rot will there
be anything
that will be remotely american and and
relative to equality instead of equity
and all of the good things
about america will we have any of that
by the time this thing burns out
i'm not totally sure and nobody's coming
to save you
you are the only one that can save
yourself and if you want proof just
listen to this ridiculous story
from california california lawmakers
have introduced a bill
to hold social media companies
accountable
for online hate we've got a quote here
right from the district 45
website this is the district that this
uh this piece of legislation
is coming from this is like their press
release that they put on their website
california legislators introduce
bipartisan effort to hold social media
companies
accountable for online hate and
disinformation
groundbreaking legislation would require
social media companies to
publicly displa disclose corporate
policies and key metrics regarding
online hate
disinformation and extremism
it goes on assembly member jesse gabriel
who's a democrat from woodland hills
today announced new legislation that
will bring much needed transparency and
accountability to the role of social
media platforms
in amplifying extreme and dangerous
content and driving severe political
polarization the first of its kind
measure the social media transparency
and accountability act of 2021
would require social media platforms to
publicly disclose their corporate
policies regarding online hate
disinformation extremism harassment and
foreign interference
as well as key metrics and data
regarding enforcement of
those policies okay so let's uh
let's talk about this jesse gabriel
because actually i've got a quote from
him and then i'll explain why because
some of that does sound kind of good
like transparency
but what the real danger is but assembly
member jesse gabriel said this
californians are becoming increasingly
alarmed about the role
of social media in promoting hate
disinformation
conspiracy theories and extreme
political polarization
it's long past time for these companies
to provide real transparency into their
content moderation
practices the public and policy makers
deserve to know when and how social
media companies are amplifying certain
voices
and silencing others this is an
important first step in a broader
effort to protect our democracy and
better regulate
social media platforms okay so a lot of
this sounds good right but there's a
there's a little bit of a confusion here
there's a difference between
transparency so would i like these
companies to be transparent about their
policies
do you de-boost or de-rank or
algorithmically manipulate
equally what is your policy on that and
does it affect say people on the right
as
much as people on the left do you delete
lefty accounts as much as you delete
righty accounts
is all of that transparent and good i
would like to see more transparency
there
the problem is when they start talking
about political polarization
and misinformation they don't mean that
they're going to get rid of
misinformation as if when cnn broadcasts
their misinformation
that we talk about here all the time
right when washington post makes up a
story that's not the type of
disinformation
that they're going to get rid of the
type of disinformation
that they're going to get rid of is
perhaps when trump supporters
say something or a conservative comes
out against
some new trans bill or whatever it might
be
right like some basically anything as i
say all the time that is not
woke will be considered disinformation
so there's a huge difference between uh
the government asking
these companies to be transparent tell
us what you're doing
so that we can see that you're treating
people fairly because then that gets us
into that publisher
verse platform conversation right
section 230 of the communications act
that's a great place to have a
conversation
i love that conversation if you haven't
seen my interview with uh with david
sacks from a couple weeks ago you should
check it out he gives a really great
explainer on that
but that is very different than saying
we're going to force you guys meaning we
the government are going to force you
to watch out and do something about
certain content that is misinformation
or politically polarizing or something
else
because then what is the government
doing what does the first amendment say
the first amendment says you have the
right to free speech the government
right cannot encroach on your right to
free speech but what if the government
forces a company to encroach on your
free speech so your guy here
then you've got tech company here and
the government here well the government
knows you can't run around to get you
right first amendment that's tough for
those guys i know they're not thrilled
with it
so what they can do is they can create
laws to make sure that that guy has to
do something
and i would argue and i think many
lawyers would argue and i've heard many
people argue this that that
then would be a violation of your first
amendment by the way this guy the
district that he covers is woodland
hills which that's the home depot
that i go to and last time i was there
you know he's worried about
online misinformation last time i was at
home depot swear to you this happened
there was a crazy man attacking people
with a golf club
chasing people out of the store i almost
took a video of it
and i know it would have went viral and
i'm not even going to tell you the race
of the person
or the race of some of the people he was
uh changing uh chasing around but let's
just say it didn't quite fit the
narrative that cnn would have been
uh thrilled with but literally there was
a man chasing people around the garden
section
we were trying to get tomato plants we
did get them eventually but we had to
wait outside for a little bit
it was a whole thing um and the other
funny thing about that woodland hills
you got to google this
that woodland hills home depot is like a
block away from it there is a building
i've posted this picture on twitter a
couple times there is a building that's
workspace
and apartments and condos uh and just
like a whole giant complex and it's
called the queue
so it has a giant queue outside of it so
you
now the q people they have a brick and
mortar okay they're building
in woodland hills and these guys worry
about online misinformation
lordy lordy lordy uh guys just a
reminder uh part one of my interview
with janice dean is up right now she's
just phenomenal
this woman is like truly truly just
great it was one of the most enjoyable
interviews i've done in a long time
and she's fighting andrew cuomo and her
story about
you know her her in-laws were two of the
people that were sent back into the
old age homes that died and she just she
didn't take it lying down she's fighting
for them it's
it's just absolutely incredible uh and a
lot of good stuff is happening at
reubenreport.locals.com
that that big announcement that i've
been teasing about locals i already
announced it
on the community at
reubenreport.locals.com we're going to
make a public announcement uh probably
in a day or two we're just working
through a couple things
but a lot of good stuff's happening and
i'm happy to report that
hope you enjoyed the show hope you have
a great day and i'll see you tomorrow